Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Pizza Hut in the US and in India.
This is "Food Wars."
The smallest pizza in the US
is the personal pan pizza,
and it is 6 inches across.
In India, our pizzas
start at personal size.
It's seven inches wide
and has four slices.
The US also has a small pizza,
but only with the gluten-free crust,
and it is
difficult.
10 inches wide. So depressing looking.
Then we're on to the mediums.
A medium pizza here in India is 10 inches
and has six slices.
Joe: A US medium pizza
comes in at 12 inches wide.
This medium pizza is equal
to the small pizza in the US.
People in the US, sometimes
it's just really hard
not to stereotype you guys.
Next up in India, we have nothing.
Because medium is our largest size.
That's right, we have only
two sizes, personal or medium.
No large for us because
Pizza Hut is watching our weight, I guess.
Stereotype away, my man,
because in the US, you
know we got this large,
and it is 14 inches in diameter.
So America's largest pizza
is 4 inches wider than India's largest.
That doesn't sound so bad.
However.
If you calculate the surface
area of the two pizzas,
those few inches make a big difference.
The Indian medium has a surface
area of 78.5 square inches,
while the US large clocks
in at 153.9 square inches.
To save you from doing the
math, that's a 96% increase.
That means the US large pizza
is nearly double our Indian medium.
What the heck, Pizza Hut?
The type of crust you get
doesn't affect the width of the pizza,
but how does it affect the value?
We're going to weigh a
medium hand-tossed slice
versus a medium pan-crust slice
to see which one gives you
more pizza for your money.
All right, I'm going to
do the same with our pan
and San Francisco-style
pizzas, the medium size.
All right. So, medium hand-tossed weighs
94 grams.
Pan, the thick boy.
Boy!
Whoa! 104 grams.
That's a difference of --
what was the first one?
That's a difference of this many grams.
This one is pan style,
and it weighs 78 grams.
This slice
weighs 66 grams.
Fairly lighter,
and I think this is because
when they make this pizza,
they press it down into the pan,
and that's the San Francisco style.
This weighs more and therefore is more,
'cause it's more bread.
You want the cheese and the sauce.
You want the fun stuff, right?
I don't -- no.
Oh, boy, this is gonna be trouble.
Here is everything you'll find on the menu
at Pizza Hut India that you
will not find in the US.
And here are all the Pizza
Hut menu items from the US
you won't find in India.
Let's start off with the
foundation of any pizza:
the crust, starting with
the San Francisco signature style.
To my understanding, it's
basically a pan pizza,
but they press the dough
in with their hands
so it's kind of hand-tossed.
Next up, we have something very special.
It's a Schezwan pan pizza.
Oh, my God, yeah. I really like this.
It's spicy. Really yum.
Just to give you some comparison,
the way chicken tikka masala
was invented in the UK
but clearly inspired by Indian cuisine,
Schezwan sauce was actually
invented here in Kolkata
by the Chinese community
that settled down here.
But it's obviously inspired
by Chinese cuisine,
and now it's become
part of Indian cuisine.
We have accepted it wholly,
and we eat it all across India.
Very exciting to see it integrated
into the Pizza Hut menu,
and it actually tastes
very good on this pizza.
Next up they have a
stuffed cheese crust Maxx,
with two X's for emphasis.
You can already see that this
thing is loaded with cheese.
Next to the cheese, alongside it,
there's, like, a sort of creamy sauce,
which Pizza Hut is calling
Peruvian creamy sauce.
Whoa!
Oh, my God, yeah. This is decadent food.
Next up we have a stuffed
crust with veg kebab.
That's right. If you
don't know what kebab is,
it's basically meat that's
cooked in a tandoor.
If you don't know what a tandoor is,
please go watch the older
episodes of "Food Wars."
I've explained it eight times.
A lot of people like to
leave the crust behind,
but I feel like Pizza Hut is making sure
all of the pizza is eaten,
because even this looks
like a dish in itself at this point.
Oh, my God, that's really yum.
And the final option:
the stuffed crust with
a non-vegetarian kebab.
Ooh.
As you can see, this is what
looks to be chicken seekh.
Oh, that's the best of the lot.
That was amazing. Oh, my God.
Smashed it, Pizza Hut.
That might be the best pizza
I've had on "Food Wars" so far,
and I didn't even eat the pizza part.
We also have a variety of
crust options in the US,
starting down here. You saw it already.
Here it is again, the hand-tossed.
This to me is, like,
classic. This is the default.
You guys don't have hand-tossed?
Moving on: Thin 'N Crispy.
I mean, how much -- look at this.
They can't charge the same
amount for this, right?
I don't think they should.
Moving on over here: the
original stuffed crust.
They put cheese in the crust.
Can you believe that?
Ugh, no, it is solidified.
That doesn't stop me from biting into it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Last and, let's be honest,
least: gluten-free crust.
Look, I don't know what's
going on with gluten allergies,
and my apologies if you have
one, but I'm looking at this,
I'm just like, I'm sorry, guys.
I mean, is this that much better?
I don't know how you can enjoy this.
And for a limited time,
Pizza Hut in the US has
Detroit-style pizza!
Let's go! Let us go.
Look at this. Are you
kidding me with this?
Detroit-style pizza. What's Detroit style?
Well, they cook it in a square
pan that has sides to it.
It's like when you cook brownies
and every brownie is
a corner or end piece.
It's like that, for pizza.
So every slice is going to have
the crispy crust on the
outside. It's thicker.
One of my favorite pizza styles.
I'm glad Pizza Hut's doing it.
Generous with the pepperoni,
guys. I appreciate it.
Not the best Detroit-style
pizza I've ever had,
but it's pretty good.
I think they go bread,
cheese, topping, sauce.
These are the toppings we
found under the categories
classic, favorites, and delight.
Very arbitrarily named,
but, yeah, let's jump into it.
The first option is chicken sausage.
Smells really good.
A lot of onions. I love onions.
Mm.
It's pretty classic.
The next pizza is spiced paneer.
Paneer, if you don't
know, is cottage cheese.
We make it all over the
place here in India,
and it's one of our favorite ingredients.
We use it on everything, even pizzas.
Not very spicy,
but definitely it's got,
like, a tangy twist to it.
Next up we have the Veggie Feast.
It's got some herbed onion,
capsicum, and sweet corn.
This is such a wholesome, chill pizza.
It's definitely a classic.
It's something your
mom would make at home.
Next up, we have the veggie tandoori,
which I have already taken a bite of.
We got this one with the Schezwan crust,
so it's definitely spicier
than the typical pan pizza you'll get.
And I already tasted it,
and I told you I loved it.
I love the spice.
Next up, we have spiced
chicken meat-a-balls!
It's a very straightforward pizza,
but we got it with the
cheese-burst filling.
Next up, we have the
Chicken N Corn Delight.
It already has the word
"delight" in the name,
so I'm assuming it should be a delight,
but I'll be the judge of that.
Capsicum; chicken, just
strewn across; and corn.
It's got too much going on, I would say.
Personally, I would not
order a pizza like this.
Next up, to round it all off,
this is the double chicken sausage pizza.
Am I wrong in saying
that this just looks like
a boring version of the
normal chicken sausage pizza,
which has onions and
just feels a lot better?
We have a pepperoni pizza
that is made of pork and not chicken
and a Pepperoni Lover's pizza.
Which one has more pepperoni?
I can't tell!
The supreme pizza.
It has pepperoni, mushrooms,
green peppers, onions,
and that's it.
But if that's not
supreme-y enough for you,
we have the super supreme,
which, now they've
introduced black olives.
Meat Lover's, baby!
Meat Lover's!
You got pepperoni, you got
bacon, you got sausage.
I bet there's something else on there
that I don't know, another meat.
I just, it's beautiful.
This next pizza is the Veggie Lover's,
and I absolutely hate it.
You want veggies? Go get a
salad. Don't put it on pizza.
Like, you're not fooling
anyone, all right?
Backyard barbecue chicken.
Yuelei, do you have enough B-roll?
I think, it's barbecue chicken,
but I think they use barbecue
sauce instead of pizza sauce.
Genius. Genius!
This is so good.
Oh, yeah! The Buffalo chicken.
It's, like, surprisingly good.
Pizza Hut does not have a straight
Hawaiian pizza on the menu.
The only thing they have
is Hawaiian chicken.
I see, obviously, chicken.
I see a pineapple.
I think I see ham? Yep.
I think Hawaiian should
just be pineapple and bacon,
and if you want to throw some
chicken on it that's fine,
but if you have a strong opinion
either for or against pineapple
on pizza, you're wrong.
It's a perfectly fine topping.
I don't know why everyone
gets so worked up about it.
More pizzas, and these are all part
of the signature collection.
There are 11 pizzas in front of me?
Two, four, six ... ah, OK.
First off, the Country Feast.
It looks super saucy.
It's all loaded with vegetables.
There's mushrooms,
capsicum, onion, sweet corn,
roasted peppers; everything that you want
on a country-themed pizza.
All right, next up we
have tandoori paneer.
If you remember in the
previous categories,
we had spiced paneer.
So all I'm looking for
is, why is this different?
Oh, my God, that's really yum.
Next up is the Veggie Lover.
It's basically got
tomato, onion, capsicum,
mushrooms, and some red paprika
and hopefully a whole lot of flavor.
It's underwhelming. I'm gonna be honest.
Next up, we have chicken tikka.
Everybody knows chicken tikka.
It's a bit too strong, too tangy,
and I think they could have gone
with a thinner layer of sauce.
Next up we have the malai chicken tikka.
Malai is basically cream.
So malai kebabs, they
basically grill the chicken
and they pour malai on top.
We have the chicken pepperoni.
Double paneer supreme.
You like paneer? You like Supreme clothes?
Well, this has double of
it, minus the clothes.
Veggie supreme.
Everybody in India has
heard of this pizza.
This is a painting.
I can genuinely see this on
the wall of an art gallery.
There's capsicum, there's
olives, there's corn,
there's onions, there's corn again.
Veg Kebab Surprise.
I'm curious to know what's
gonna be surprising about this.
Surprise, surprise, it tastes bland.
And now on to our
penultimate signature pizza.
This is the chicken tikka supreme!
Woohoo!
Basically what they've
done is they've taken
four different kinds of chicken
and they put it on a pizza.
And finally, in the line
of signature pizzas,
we have Triple Chicken Feast.
It has all of the above ingredients,
and we've also gone the extra mile
and taken it with a chicken
stuffing in the crust.
Overall, Pizza Hut has actually killed it.
I think all the ingredients
have tasted super fresh,
all the meat has also tasted really soft
and juicy and delicious,
and the sauce has been
consistently yum throughout.
Damn, Pizza Hut. Good job.
As mentioned before,
currently have a Detroit-style
pizza at the US Pizza Hut.
This is what it looks like.
Two slices are missing.
I skipped lunch, and
breakfast, to be honest.
For those of you outside
of the United States,
Detroit is a city in Michigan.
They have their own style
of pizza. I really enjoy it.
You can also get it as
a supreme Detroit style
and a meaty deluxe Detroit style.
And I didn't get them
because it all looks exactly like this.
One fun option on the Pizza Hut India menu
is their new range of Momo Mia pizzas,
which are pan pizzas
with momos baked into the crust.
Now, if you don't know what momos are,
they're basically dumplings
from Nepal and Tibet.
They're served all across India,
and they've become huge favorites
for everybody over here.
They've also given a
Schezwan sauce to the side,
which is what you
typically eat with momos.
Hm.
No.
That ain't right. I don't
see how this is working.
I can't think of a single Italian
who would put a pocket of ravioli
on top of pizza and
then bake them together.
And this is effectively what that is.
We also have a range of
Flavour Fun personal pan pizzas
that you can get with
a host of new flavors.
Starting off with classic corn.
Next up, we have the
classic onion and capsicum.
Tandoori mushroom and corn.
So, it looks similar to this,
but it used tandoori sauce
and the varied mushrooms.
Next up, we have the classic
paneer, onion, and capsicum.
Then we have the classic chicken sausage,
but personal-pan-sized.
Next, we have the Italian
pepperoni and onion.
And just a reminder that the pepperoni
that they've used is chicken pepperoni.
Tandoori chicken tikka and onion,
and the classic loaded chicken delight.
Personally, [crickets chirping]
I wouldn't order these pans.
I would get the larger pizzas,
'cause they tasted way better.
On top of set menu items,
we can also customize our
pizzas in unique ways.
For example, if you don't want
tomato sauce as your base,
you can sub it out for
creamy garlic Parmesan,
barbecue sauce, remember from before?
Buffalo sauce, or a no-sauce option
if you are a maniac.
And if you want you can specify light,
regular, or extra sauce.
Unfortunately, we can't change the sauces
on our pizza bases,
but we have a bunch of custom toppings
that you will not find in the US,
like baby corn, sweet
corn, herbed veggies,
spiced paneer, and veg kebab.
And we also have exclusive toppings
you cannot get in India.
For instance, we have
pepperoni, which is pork;
our Italian sausage has pork;
bacon, ah, I believe is pork;
meatballs, beef and pork;
ham, pork;
and then beef;
and pork.
Then the vegetables: We got white onion;
we got pineapple, which is a fruit;
and we have banana
peppers, which I don't know
if it's a fruit or a
vegetable or a pepper.
Are peppers fruit?
Whenever we have the
option of customizations
on "Food Wars," we like
to combine all of our
exclusive ingredients to
make an India-only pizza.
So this pizza has a Schezwan
base with baby corn,
veg kebab, spiced paneer,
and herbed veggies.
It looks pretty gnarly, I'm not gonna lie,
but let's see how it tastes.
Hm.
I can see why Pizza Hut didn't put this
officially on their menu,
'cause maybe the ingredients
don't go that well together,
but, hey, this is an
India-only Pizza Hut pizza,
and that means something.
And, of course, we had to
create our own US-only pizza.
So, the thin crispy base,
creamy garlic Parmesan sauce,
beef, bacon, white onion,
and everyone's favorite
vegetable, banana peppers.
No!
This looks like a cartoon pizza.
Ah.
OK, it's not bad.
It's not great. I wouldn't get it.
Yeah, it tastes like onion and bacon.
Don't get this.
Oop!
Pizza Hut has a bunch of sides.
So, let's start off with the breads.
First off, we have cheese garlic bread.
Then we have spicy supreme
cheese garlic bread.
It's basically cheese melted
on top of a garlic bread baguette.
It's got some green chili
and some chopped onions.
It's very delicious when it's hot.
Mexican garlic breadsticks.
Oregano sprinkled on top,
some jalapeño, some
chopped olives, and onions.
It looks really delicious.
Creamy garlic breadsticks.
And finally we have garlic
breadsticks in a little packet
that says "GARLIC BREAD STIX."
The US Pizza Hut only offers
regular breadsticks and cheese sticks.
So, in fact, the only
actual exclusive side
that we have in the US is fries.
We have a bunch of other sides,
including baked cheesy momos veg
and baked cheesy momos non-veg.
Whew. That's a potent smell.
You know what?
It's not half bad.
Next up we have potato poppers,
which are pretty much Tater Tots.
We have the Indi Rockin Roll veg
and the Indi Rockin Roll non-veg.
This is basically a roll,
but I like how the wrap is kind of thin.
Again, it's quite good.
Next up, we have the zesty paneer pocket
and the zesty chicken pocket.
These are pretty much like pizza pockets.
There's some mint mayo, some
normal mayo, some cream cheese,
chicken, and jalapeños.
We have jalapeño poppers.
I imagine they're just filled with cheese
and some jalapeño bits.
Oh, ugh, I did not
expect that consistency.
And that brings us to an
old classic: chicken wings.
Spicy baked chicken wings.
So I suppose they're a
healthier alternative?
WingStreet wings.
Yes!
Both traditional and boneless.
You can get them in the following flavors.
Lemon pepper. Oh, let's go, lemon pepper.
I usually don't like lemon pepper,
but these are pretty good.
Ooh, honey barbecue.
Ugh, these things are like condensation.
Ah, ooh, the medium Buffalo.
Ooh, Cajun style!
Eh, just OK.
Spicy garlic. What?
Naked. That's wings with nothing on it.
Why would you do that? I don't know.
Buffalo Burnin' Hot.
Three flames!
Mm, this should be your medium.
Oh, wait!
Yeah, OK.
Sweet chili.
Am I sweating? I feel like I'm sweating.
They're all just eh. You
know, I mean, I like wings.
Maybe my wing standards are too high.
Garlic Parmesan. Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
[sighs]
Oh, my God!
I mean, the sauce is like
pasta sauce. It's really thick.
It's got a lot of flavor to it,
but it's just, like, sitting in the sauce,
so either you get a
mouthful of sauce or none.
And these come in portions
of six, 12, 18, or 36.
And next up on the menu,
you can also find a range of pastas,
starting with the creamy mushroom.
[sauce squishing]
You know what? If I have to
listen to this, so will you all.
[sauce squishing]
Just get some in the boom mic.
Decent pasta for a fast-food restaurant.
They have a cheesy comfort veg pasta
and a cheesy comfort chicken pasta.
It's too gooey.
We have the spiced Tomato Twist veg pasta
and the spiced Tomato Twist non-veg pasta.
If you come to Pizza Hut to order pasta,
I hope we never cross paths.
Nikhil, you have no idea.
We absolutely love our
carbs in this country.
And as you can see,
we have bowls and bowls of
carbs that we call pasta.
You can get four exclusive
oven-baked pastas
at pa -- pasta hut. At Pizza Hut.
I'm not eating any of these.
They all taste terrible.
All right? The end.
You can get a oven-baked
chicken Alfredo. Don't get this.
Or, if you don't like chicken,
you can just get cheesy Alfredo.
And then, of course, we have
the Italian meats pasta,
which is pepperoni and Italian sausage.
I mean, oh, Italy. Oh, Italy.
I'm so sorry.
And, lastly, the oven-baked veggie pasta.
I mean, this is a doorstop.
I can't stand the Pizza Hut pasta.
I cannot stand it.
You see the sauces. You
know what time it is.
Sauce talk.
Starting down here, get
yourself blue cheese sauce,
then get ranch.
Ooh, a garlic sauce.
We can have a honey barbecue sauce,
a medium Buffalo sauce,
and a side of marinara,
just for dipping your breadsticks.
And also icing, the Cinnabon
icing for the Cinnabuns.
And there's a note that says,
"I really want to see Joe dipping
some pizza in the frosting
and eat it."
[sighs]
Give me this.
Oh!
Actually ...
At first I was like, yuck,
but this is kind of good.
And now on to dips. You dips---s.
First off, we have tomato ketchup. Ha ha.
[crew laughing]
Then we have a mayonnaise.
Fun fact: It's veg mayonnaise,
doesn't have any egg, because a huge
population of this country
is pure vegetarians,
which means that they don't eat anything
from an animal, even egg.
Then we have a cheese dip.
And finally, it's a Schezwan sauce.
And they serve it with the momos,
they serve it with a
bunch of other things.
Yeah.
We got desserts you're
not gonna find in India.
That includes, down here,
the cinnamon sticks.
They're like breadsticks, only cinnamony.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho.
Get your mind out of the gutter.
And moving on, we have here are the
Cinnabon mini cinnamon rolls.
This is the triple chocolate brownie.
If I had to guess, 2 pounds.
What do we got here? The
ultimate chocolate chip cookie.
Right?
This is like a Frisbee.
And for all you sweetie pies
out there with sweet tooths,
here are India's exclusive desserts,
starting with a choco lava cake, baby!
Ooh!
Molten.
The choco lava cake in
Domino's? Much better.
Next up, you get a whole
range of ice cream.
Some Kwality Wall's,
one of India's biggest
ice cream manufacturers.
You can get a tiny tub of
Choco-Tastic Supreme Sundae.
Then you can get a Cornetto, a cone.
Super delicious. And I
really love the end of this,
because it's just a block of chocolate,
and I used to fight over
this with my friends.
Then you get a Magnum.
Everybody loves a Magnum.
And finally, you can even get
a family pack of ice cream.
Soda!
Last exclusive are, of course, the drinks.
Both countries have Pepsi,
but the Pizza Hut in the US
you can also get wild
cherry Pepsi, orange Crush,
Mountain Dew, baby!
Sierra Mist, which they didn't have,
and Aquafina.
Here in Pizza Hut India,
our exclusive drink options
are Pepsi, 7Up, Mirinda, and Pepsi black.
They also serve an iced
tea at the restaurant,
but they don't deliver it, unfortunately.
I would've gone for the iced tea.
All right, now let's take a
look at Pizza Hut's pricing,
particularly some clever marketing tricks
they're using to make you
believe you're getting
more value for money
than you actually are.
In the US, a medium cheese
pizza on the pan crust
will cost you $13.49.
In India, a medium Margherita
pizza will cost you
319 rupees, which is
currently 3.93 US dollars.
That means over here you
are paying 11.9 cents
per square inch of pizza.
While over here in India,
you're just paying 4.4 cents
per square inch of pizza.
That makes the US pizza
170% more expensive.
Generally with pizza, the more you buy,
the cheaper it gets.
A US large has a surface
area of 153.9 square inches
and costs $15.49.
That brings the cost per
square inch down to 10 cents,
making it 15% cheaper than the medium.
Ladies and gentlemen, it's
time for pizza pop quiz!
Which has the higher surface area,
one medium pizza or two personal pizzas?
If you said two personal
pizzas, congratulations!
You're an idiot.
Because when it comes to
calculating the surface area
of a circle, small changes in diameter
can create huge differences
in surface area.
On the Pizza Hut India website,
you can get a combo offer
of two personal pan pizzas for rupees 279.
However, a medium pizza
costs pretty much the same.
But I guess if you want two
different flavors of pizza,
it makes sense to go with the combo.
In this medium cheese pan-crust pizza,
it is 1,940 calories,
79 grams of total fat, 33
grams of saturated fat,
224 grams of carbs, and
the sodium, oh, boy,
3,480 milligrams.
A medium Margherita pizza
in India will cost you
1,377 calories,
total fat 40.29 grams,
of which saturates are 14.7 grams,
carbohydrates, 192 grams,
and 2,717 milligrams of sodium.
Yikes.
Now, the American stats look a lot worse,
but I do want to point out that our medium
is much larger than India's.
So if you break it down per square inch,
you'll see that the US version
does have more fat and more saturated fat,
but India's pizza actually contains
more calories, carbs, and sodium.
But what about the most calorific
item on the Indian menu?
If you really want to mess up your day,
you have to order the medium
veg Surprise Kebab pizza
with veg-kebab-stuffed crust.
A whole one of these pizzas will contain
2,673 calories.
That's 133.65% of your daily
caloric-intake allowance.
Oh, my God.
OK, the calories are high,
but the sodium is even higher.
There is 6,344 milligrams
of sodium in here,
which is 275% of your daily
recommended allowance.
What about the most calorific
pizza in the US, you ask?
Well, that would be a large
pan-crusted Meat Lover's,
which this isn't.
So imagine it bigger and thicker. OK.
An entire one of these contains a whopping
3,570 calories.
That's 178% of your daily allowance.
And the sodium is even
worse than that of India's.
There's 7,150 milligrams
of sodium in here.
That is 298%
your daily recommended amount.
Also, this pizza is
not particularly round.
It's shaped like a --
one, two, three, four,
five, six -- hexagon.
Look at that.
Just a fun fact in case
you're a geometry nerd.